Три – два – один! Давай!
Щороку цей неймовірний різдвяний будиночок
запалюється вогнями у день першого Адвенту.
Для такого шедевру знадобилося понад
півмільйона барвистих лампочок у гірляндах.
Це новий рекорд не лише для німецького міста
Калле у Нижній Саксонії, а й не виключено, що й для цілої Європи.
Ці вогні приголомшують!
Неймовірно!
Я б так не зміг!
Якщо подумати, скільки сил потрібно,
аби прикрасити будинок однією гірляндою,
то це просто неймовірно!
Винуватцем такого щорічного різдвяного паломництва
до міста Калле є Рольф Фоґт
пенсіонер, пристрасть якого - різдвяні вогні.
Це найбільше почуття щастя,
коли люди радіють і захопливо вигукують «ах» і «ох»!
Я думаю, це чудово.
Підготовка до Різдва займає у Фоґта півроку.
Найбільшою помічницею є його дружина Нерміна.
Вона робить всі внутрішні декорації та все інше.
Або розповідає, як це буде виглядати!
Ідея такого будинку виникла у 1999 році,
коли він з дружиною побував у гостях у свого сина у США.
Там усі будинки світилися різдвяними вогнями.
А в Німеччині такого не було.
Один будинок був ліпшим за інший.
Із святковими садками, оленями і Санта-Клаусами.
Тоді ми сказали: зробимо те саме у себе вдома!
З кожним роком вогнів ставало дедалі більше.
Вона не вірила, що коли-небудь це досягне таких масштабів!
Те, що почалося з невеликої ідеї,
потребувало гігантських зусиль та інвестицій.
Щоб все працювало злагоджено, Рольф мав
прокласти понад чотири кілометри кабелів.
Лише вологий клімат викликає занепокоєння.
Тому раз на тиждень він змушений все висушувати спеціальним приладом.
Рольф Фогт інвестував у своє хоббі,
за його власними підрахунками,
150 тисяч євро.
За різдвяний час струм за освітлення будинку
обходиться йому у додаткових 3000 євро.
Він фінансує це завдяки невеликому власному різдвяному ринку.
Близько півтисячі гостей приїздять сюди у передріздвяний час.
І поки дружина продає сосиски та глінтвейн,
Рольф стежить, аби всі його гірлянди функціонували.
Допоки вистачатиме наших сил,
ми будемо влаштовуватимемо таке свято.
Не лише заради мене чи моїх друзів, але і для всіх людей.
Рольф та Нерміна одружені вже 42 роки.
17 з них - вони влаштовують таку різдвяну казку.
І це ще далеко не кінець.